foreign
North Carolina what's up Elle is it
Ellie or l
it's l l very cool that's awesome
it's a beautiful name L you should I
don't know if I was you I would just
have one letter that'd be kind of player
but that's all right so what's up
um sorry I'm really nervous
um so I guess my question is like how
how do you make sure that you're 100
sure about someone that you're about to
marry like how do you know that they're
the right person
oh gross do you have one
what do you mean like are you dating
somebody right now and you're like I
don't know I don't know
well
yeah gross I'm just kidding oh that's
awesome so what's giving you pause
what's giving you pause all right let me
let me just to answer your question
there's zero no chance no way no how
there's no such thing as like 100 it
doesn't exist
and I'll also say that the only
marriages that make like the news or the
sensationalists not like you know what I
mean the millions and millions and
millions and millions of people who do
life together with their spouse for
their whole life that that's just not
Sensational news so it doesn't we don't
see those those people
yeah I mean I feel like I've been
listening to your show for a little bit
and and
um
and I mean my my parents are divorced
myself so it's just like I don't I feel
like all I hear about when it comes to
marriage is that you know people hide
things and then they come out later and
then there's just so much heartbreak and
yeah I mean everybody seems to always
ask you know like oh how did I how could
I have seen this before it happened and
things like that and
um
it gives me so much
uh I guess anxiety about it and
um I I feel like I'm just not super
confident in
most of my decisions but it's probably
one of them
ah man the fact that you are cautious
about making big decisions tells me that
you're very very wise
really yes so here's a couple of my
entry points into this question okay
number one
do we hold similar values and they don't
have to be word for 100 for 100 but do
we hold similar values tightly and do we
hold our beliefs very loosely
I have a value that I will always be
curious
always going to be asking the next
question I think that's really important
I seek out places where I'm wrong
that's of a value
and I like people around me to share
that because it makes my community
humble and
more interested in getting to the right
answer and helping people than defending
themselves
then on top of that value I have a
million different beliefs
and some of them are categorically wrong
they're incorrect some of them I was so
I've I've spoken at Medical School I've
spoken to medical school about 10 years
ago gave this big long lecture on
something about nutrition I can't tell
you how incorrect I was L it's
embarrassing looking back I'm just wrong
I was wrong
and so I hold my beliefs very Loosely
and I want the person that I'm going to
be with I want to have similar values
when it comes to Faith maybe we believe
different things but we both believe
we share the value that belief in
something bigger than ourselves is
crucial to our lives cool and then I'm
gonna hold it really Loosely and when my
wife comes in and says I think I
interpret this particular thing this way
I go huh tell me more because I'm not um
tied to you've got to have the same
beliefs that's insane that's why we read
books so we get new beliefs right okay
so values and beliefs that's number one
the other thing that I think the data
suggests is more important is this
how do you come back
from disagreement
from fights when one person gets off the
tracks
um Esther perel talks about the the part
of the cycle uh that's called repair how
do y'all repair things do you pretend it
never happened do you scream and yell
and kick do you dissect it do you
somebody want to talk about and talk
about it talk about it or somebody want
to use it as a weapon to get what they
want in the relationship or do you both
dig in and solve it how are we going to
come back together not if but when we
get sideways
and somewhere along the way in your
parents marriage I'm and I'm just using
them because you brought them up
the repair cycle
was
um they weren't able to reconcile it
or somebody did a thing or somebody was
struggling or somebody had a different
picture for their life when they laid
that picture out
um the other person said well then I'm
out
and so I want to know how we're going to
address problems how we're going to
discuss them and by the way that will
shift and change too
the question is are they going to shift
and change with us so tell me about this
guy you're with
um
he's great
um we do I mean we we've been together
since
um you know like the early like the
first two years of college and then we
stayed together after graduation and
um we had one major breakup
uh my senior year and
after that like uh at least in my
family's eyes
he was
I mean he couldn't come back from it and
your family doesn't get a vote
right
but it's really hard to
you're gonna care and it's Gonna Hurt
it's gonna be painful
and at some point how old are you
I'm 22. yeah it's at some point you're
gonna have to decide I'm being with this
person
and then the adults in your life are
gonna have to choose
um
are they going to be with you or are
they going to choose their their high
horse
and that's that's those are the only two
choices
my wife and I broke up five times
over the course of five years maybe four
and a half times
and then we've almost broken up several
times over the 20 years we've been
married it's hard
it's messy
but when things look grim and when
they'll like when it looks like there's
so much smoke I can't see forward
one of us always says I'm going back to
the table I hope you'll join me
because that's one of our values is you
always go back to the table
go ahead so sorry I was just gonna say I
wish that people would
um
be more honest about that aspect of
relationships because we do
I mean it's gotten better but we do tend
to bicker a lot and you know we have
disagreements and we get pretty upset
but you know people since we've been
together have always told us like oh you
know this this you shouldn't be together
I mean it just shouldn't be that way and
I mean
it's discouraging and it makes me have
the impression that you know your
relationship is always supposed to be
perfect and you know you're not there's
no such thing ever
yeah there's just no such thing
and let's be super clear our
um
I'm a very good sophisticated fighter I
don't do a lot of bickering
but I've got some pretty nasty
conversations that I have in my head
that nobody ever hears
right so my body's at war with my wife
even though she doesn't even know she's
just over there like doing her thing
doesn't even know we're in a fight and
vice versa at least you guys are saying
it out loud
what I would want to get to is beneath
that
what is what is the bickering for
well currently we're
we're okay and that's
and that's very very hard it's
hard to
um you know like communicate wants and
needs and you know um
I think insecurities can roll in and are
you kidding me they come in like they
come in like a military Invasion
yes so how long are y'all planning on
doing this long distance
make a choice
so well he's he's active duty so he
needs to finish school before he can
move with me but that's going to be
another like few months yeah talking all
tough and you're like oh he's active
duty and so I'm super wrong see there I
am I'm wrong again
um here's here's the hardest part about
a relationship okay I think
the hardest part is it only works if you
go all in
a marriage only works if you go all in
and
if you go all in you can get hurt really
really bad
but if you try to hedge your bet you try
to put one foot in one foot out all your
feet both feet in but just a few toes
out
it's gonna fail
it'll fail every time
you gotta go or it may not fail
spectacularly in some big catastrophic
implosion
but you'll end up like millions and
millions and millions of people across
our country where you're just roommates
yeah they're good co-managers of your
house but you're not in a relation
you're not all in
y'all sleep together twice a month I
mean it's whatever but you're not all in
so the greatest advice I could give you
is
if you're gonna go go all in pack up and
move
like to quote the great Good Will
Hunting go see about a girl go see about
a guy
go all in
and just know the only way this thing
works is by going all in and man you are
opening yourself up for a heartache that
is unfathomably painful
and relationships ultimately ultimately
become
me looking across the table at my wife
in the eyes and saying
I'm gonna give you everything
please don't hurt me
I'm going to tell you everything
please don't use it against me
I'm going to show you my soul
please see it and love me anyway
and she says the same thing back
and L just saying that out loud is scary
hearing that is that scary
that's it
so are you in
I would like to ideally say that I am
scared I'm scared also of like
just being alone in the end if it
doesn't work out because you're alone
right now a lot of times you're alone
right now
you're alone with somebody right next to
you
what does that mean
that means you're living parallel lives
with somebody who's become a little bit
more than a figment of your imagination
because y'all are doing this thing long
distance
and you're insecure and you're doubtful
and you're unanchored
and he is too
and so this idea like I'm just gonna end
up alone people sacrifice deep love for
for partnership for somebody sitting on
it like next to you for proximity
do you know what I'm saying
yeah
you're worth more than halfway
and he is too quite frankly
I would love to see what happens in this
thing if you go all in
and I think it's perfectly fair to say I
say these words in my marriage so
I'm scared that I'm gonna put all my
cards on the table and you're gonna
cash out and leave
and that's scary
and the only way this thing works is to
push all your chips in that's why I tell
people to share a banking account that's
why I tell people to be honest with each
other and not keep secrets not be a
and over share but don't keep
secrets
that's why I tell people
hold the other person very very loosely
because they're a human they're gonna
breathe and they're gonna fail and
they're gonna have new thoughts and new
imaginations and want to go down new
rabbit holes
your job isn't to squeeze them so tight
that everybody stays connected nah man
it's to be incomplete and total trust
and love and vulnerability the whole
thing
go all in L go all in here's what I
think I think you really like this guy I
think you love this guy
and I think you've got enough voices
around you I think you've got enough uh
personal experiences around you
that tell you that
going all in that type of love is not
safe and it's not wise
and your body's probably right because
you've seen people get hurt
the choice here you have to make for
yourself is am I going to do it anyway
I'll tell you in my life it's made all
the difference
all of it